der förderturm
wahrzeichen des ruhrgebiets
jetzt hat die letzte zeche dicht gemacht
tausende jobs gingen verloren
und ein teil der seele einer ganzen
region 33 jahren jetzt zu wissen
gleiches schluss nicht schön
tief unter der erde bleibt ein
schwieriges erbe
denn der abbau der kohle hat spuren
hinterlassen
für immer
[Musik]
die folgen des bergbaus kann man ihn
wirklich abschätzen sind und bleiben
einfach ewigkeit aufgabe
doch der abschied von der welt unter
tage ist auch ein neubeginn
auf alten zechen siedeln sich nun junge
firmen an und rostige bergwerksgelände
bieten künstlern die große höhen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die sonne atmosphäre in so einer alten
halle musste die schwer gearbeitet würde
jetzt show zu machen und zu machen macht
ihm großen spaß
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das letzte mal kommen sie aus dem
schacht holder kinder und seine kunden
mit dem letzten stück deutscher
steinkohle liebe bergleute dass es in
der tat mehr als ein stück kohle das ist
geschichte und geschichte die kumpel
wieder geschrieben haben
wichtig waren teil der bergbaugeschichte
stellvertretend für tausende 100000 die
einer ganzen ära auf dem pütt gewesen
sind unsere arbeit gemacht haben die
arbeit geleistet haben stellvertretend
für alle
noch bis vor kurzem hat holger kinder
auf der zeche prosper haniel gearbeitet
es ist seine letzte schicht mit den
vertrauten kumpeln 33 jahre bis jetzt
aufhören kollegen verlieren war erstmal
über die kontakt haben wie sonst immer
ein letzter bergmanns und dann geht es
hinab in die welt unter tage
weg zu sagen
krass
1200 meter unter der erde
holger und die männer müssen noch
kilometer weiter zu fuß und mit dem
förderband dahin wo die kohle abgebaut
wird
30 grad stau dunkelheit schon immer ist
es knochenarbeit schon immer gefährlich
ich kann aus vier meter höhe liegenden
unterhält der markt schon gut aber wir
müssen aufpassen
ich muss auch mal zum aufbau ost noch
nicht aufgeben und wir fahren hier unten
verlassen sie sich aufeinander
dann ist brüder kommen könnte man auch
sagen
um jeder hilft auch den nummern auch das
hat die region geprägt es geht nicht
darum welche wurzeln jemand hat ob
deutsche polnische oder türkische
und unter tage ist jeder gleich da kommt
man nicht auch die nation
da guckt man nicht wo man herkommt
weiß man gleich für holger und seine
kumpel ist jetzt schluss doch unter tage
bleibt das schwierige erbe der kohle
denn wenn die vorderräder für immer
stillstehen müssen riesige punkten das
giftige grubenwasser vom grundwasser
fernhalten
was nach dem bergbau kommt kann man in
bochum sogar studieren dem lehr bergwerk
steht heute eine vermessungs übung auf
dem plan
fast alle studenten hier kommen aus
bergbau familien sowie fiona kroppen ich
denke schon dass das in irgendeiner art
und weise trägt wenn der opa allem dann
als kleines kind immer schon geschichten
aus dem werk welt erzählt und mein vater
hat auch unter tage gearbeitet als
elektriker und dann hört man halt immer
wieder so geschichten die dann die
berufserfahrung waren als sie beide noch
jünger waren
nun beschäftigt sich viel mit dem erbe
ihrer väter mit den alten schächten dem
giftigen grubenwasser es sind aufgaben
für die ewigkeit ewig heißt für immer
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie lange
geschichte in punkt werden müssen aber
daher immer neues wasser nachfließen
wird wird es eine ewige aufgabe sein und
wenn wir diese aufgabe nicht mehr
übernehmen dann kommt es halt zu den
schäden ewige aufgaben bringen aber auch
gute jobaussichten
die studenten könnten bald gefragte
experten seien im ruhrgebiet und überall
dort auf der welt wo in den nächsten
jahren zechen dicht machen werden
[Musik]
für den grundwasseranstieg ist es von
großer bedeutung zu wissen wie sich das
gewässer im untergrund verhält die
erfahrung anderer theorie und experiment
darauf sind die studenten angewiesen
sich selbst ein bild machen das geht
bald nicht mehr
ich hatte das schwierige ist dass wir
jetzt bald nicht mehr die möglichkeit
haben unter tage zu kommen
wir wissen nicht wie der zustand ist ist
ja gut ist ja schlecht ist ungefähr mit
erdbeben zu vergleichen wir können nicht
voraus an wann und ob etwas passiert
auch holger kinder kommt nie mehr unter
tage seine letzte schicht ist vorbei die
kumpel aber bleiben seine kumpel
denn die harte arbeit hat die männer
zusammen geschweißt
wann immer einer von ihnen geht sind sie
alle da und zum respekt anerkennung auch
ohne große worte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dass der abschied auch neubeginn sein
kann
das zeigt sich auf dem gelände der
hertener zeche ewald die heizzentrale
des stillgelegten bergwerks ist
inzwischen zum regietheater geworden
generalprobe für die neue travestieshow
[Musik]
die idee dazu hatte theater unternehmer
christian stratmann
genau hier wo so viel an die kohle
erinnert wollte er große shows
inszenierung als ich zum ersten mal das
gebäude gekommen bin
da habe ich nur diese verfallen wende
gesehen und war total von der atmosphäre
begeistert ich dachte in diesem raum da
muss man farbe bringen musik prägen
shows zeigen
es hat sich der raum hat mich wahnsinnig
faszinierend stratmann ist selbst ein
kind des ruhrgebiets und will das erbe
der coole bewahren wie sowieso gewesen
ist so stolz auf die fliesen immer wenn
ein riss kommt laufen er jeden abend
viele leute drüber wir müssen kojak hier
sitzen und ein bisschen fliesenkleber
damit die bloß noch weitere 100 jahre
halten
in der ehemaligen lohnhalle nebenan
haben sich inzwischen büros angemietet
mehr als 1000 jobs sind in den letzten
jahren auf dem bergwerksgelände
entstanden solchen erfolg gibt es nur
auf wenigen alten zechen hier aber soll
sich noch mehr tun
marc baumüller plant ein großes
ausstellungsgelände für oldtimer mit
hotel seilbahn und allem drum und dran
die arbeit auf der zeche ist auch für
ihn etwas besonderes und das ist schön
etwas zusammenwächst glaube der normale
gewerbepark also glaube ich hat uns bild
nicht also wir sind hier auf ewald 52
hektar stillgelegtes bergwerk viel
industriegeschichte viele schlüssel und
fiel überraschend ist die sanierte
maschinenhalle etwa wird jetzt gerne für
hochzeiten gebucht ich glaube viele
überraschungsmomente mit nach hause weil
im ruhrgebiet das gar nicht so erwartet
wird dass es hier dann doch so schön ist
oder dass er so ein strukturwandel doch
schon stattgefunden hat ich habe gelernt
wie grün das ruhrgebiet ist habe ich mir
auch gar nicht so vorgestellt
holger kinder ist seit ein paar wochen
im vorruhestand
der 50 jährige bergmann hat nun zeit für
tochter alana und radtouren durch seine
heimat dinslaken
[Musik]
es geht zur ehemaligen zeche lohberg
heute ein freizeitgelände
hier hat sie schon begonnen die zeit
nach der kohle
das ist natürlich schade dass die ganzen
leute ihre arbeitswelt zu verlieren für
die umwelt wäre es natürlich gut wenn
man halt keine kohle mehr verbrennen
würden
sondern auf windräder zb zugreifen auf
erneuerbare energie windräder statt
kohle statt bergbau das revier im wandel
hinter mir da war nur alles asche und
steine und irgendwelche materialien
darunter tage gefördert wurden und jetzt
alles grün geworden renaturiert bauland
hin wo natürlich jetzt auch häuser
entstehen aber es ist schon schön
[Musik]
zurück zur zeche ewald rund ums alte
fördert schminkten sich die künstler für
die show vor ausverkauftem haus premiere
fieber ein bisschen 'schon ja ein großes
bisschen sogar aber ja
ist ja ein anderes und immer neue leute
ein neues publikum ist immer aufregend
von der zeche zum travestie tempel
doch eine wurden das schöne daran würden
der theaterchef hat der zeche neues
leben eingehaucht
glamour statt kohlenstaub wie passt das
zusammen gar nicht das ist ja gerade das
interessante geschichte passt gar nicht
zusammen ich glaube auch dass die leute
die hier gearbeitet haben die haben über
alles nachgedacht über dich wird
travestie zwei drei mal die woche öffnet
der revuepalast seiner pforten
und es ist fast immer ausverkauft
[Musik]
wenn sie wieder alle
unsere fans zur premiere kommen auch
holger kinder und sein kumpel mike der
hat hier früher mal gearbeitet und ist
auf spurensuche
ja was ich erkenne es hier noch die
alten und leise wurde für die jungen
über gefahren haben haben sie gut
gemacht
auch wenn sich hier vieles geändert hat
der charme der alten zeche das erbe der
alten arbeitswelt sind geblieben
[Musik]
wir sind was wir sind
kumpel sind auch dann noch kumpel wenn
die kohle weg ist im revier stehen sie
zusammen
[Musik]
das ist schön
was hier so passiert mit meiner sicher
ruhig früher drauf waren und das ist
jetzt eben neue dinge dann in den alten
gebäuden entstehen und nicht einfach
abgerissen werden die kohle hat die
menschen hier geprägt die menschen hier
zusammengeschweißt es ist das ende einer
ära und der beginn von etwas neuem
[Musik]